- So I'm pleased to introduce
our guest, John Kerry
our nation's first Special
Presidential Envoy for Climate
and the first principal
to sit on the National Security Council
dedicated to climate change.
I think you know prior
to his current service
Secretary Kerry was the Carnegie Endowment
for International Peace's
first ever visiting
distinguished statesman.
He was our country's top
diplomat for four years
as the 68th United States,
Secretary of State.
He's a decorated combat veteran
and served 25 years in the U.S. Senate.
As many of you know
Secretary Kerry is a
Distinguished Fellow at Yale
in the Jackson Institute
and a member of the Yale
College Class of 1966.
So Secretary Kerry, thank
you for joining us today.
And we've gathered a lot
of questions for you.
So I wanna jump right in.
I know you'll be representing
the United States
at the 2021 United Nations
Climate Change Conference
at the end of the year.
And we'd be interested in
hearing what your goals are
for that event.
- Well, Peter, first of all,
it's great to be with a Yale Climate Day
and Michael, thank you.
And Peter, thank you for the
invitation to be with you.
We are woefully behind
where we ought to be
on an international basis.
In Paris, we all agreed to
keep the Earth's temperature
increase well below two degrees,
and if possible at 1.5 degrees centigrade.
And the truth is that we're far from that
we knew in Paris that
even if everybody did
what they were gonna do
we'd still arise in temperature
to about 3.7 degrees.
And because we're not doing everything
people said they would do
we're actually heading
four degrees or more.
So it's quite fundamentally catastrophic.
On the upside, we have the ability
to avoid the worst
consequences of climate.
We really can do this
but the next 10 years
are absolutely critical.
So the goal at Glasgow is to
bring global ambition way up.
We had a summit in the
White House last month
the President Biden hosted,
that summit resulted in
about 55% of global GDP
being committed to keep to the 1.5 degrees
that includes Japan,
Canada, the United States,
the UK, Europe, et cetera
but we're now working with the other 45%.
That's the diplomacy
of the next six months.
How do we bring everybody else on board
to change their national
determined contribution
and DC as it's called raise their ambition
so that we lay out a
plan, literally a roadmap
for 10 years to get to 2030
with preserving 1.5 degrees
and then building on the
plans to go to 2050 net zero
which more and more
people are now adopting.
The problem has Peter we
don't want to be stuck
with a whole bunch of,
wow, we're for 2050 net
zero that's our deal,
because it doesn't get us there.
You've got to get people to
buy in to the next 10 years,
that's the goal of
Glasgow, that and finance
and then what's called the rule book.
We need to kind of close out the rules
by which we're gonna implement
this over the next years.
- You know you're mentioning
the setting of goals
and the long-term
orientation that many have
when we need a decade of
this decade orientation
but it's true that with
your help many institutions,
many companies, financial companies,
others universities as
well have made pledges
to reduce admissions and have
set goals for themselves.
How can we be sure, how
can we have confidence
that there are concrete paths
toward meeting this goals
and that these institutions
actually put them in place
rather than just put the goal on a sign
and hope for the best?
- Well that's partly the rule
book that I just talked about
which is going to require updated data.
But secondly, we now have
available to us, Peter
an extraordinary array
of digital space-based
and other means of tracking
what people are doing.
Al Gore has worked on the
development of thing called TRACE
along with climate activists and others.
It's creating an ability to be able
to have real time readout on exactly
what the footprint of a global company is
or of an institution.
I mean, you could from
space focus in on Yale
and you could read out exactly
what Yale's emissions are
at that point in time and extrapolate
so that public shaming,
public accountability is
gonna be one of the things
as people buy into a global endeavor,
we're not able to have force of law
for a number of different reasons.
So this really does rely
on leveraging people
but here's the other big
thing that is happening.
And it's really exciting.
Private capital.
There is no government in the world
that has enough money to be
able to close the finance gap
that the UN has identified.
There's a one to $2 trillion
per year finance gap
just for the energy sector
in the transition we need to
make in the next 30 years.
So how do you do this?
Well, we've gone to individual
finance institutions.
We've got six of the
largest banks in America.
They've created a floor of a commitment
over the next 10 years that
will put about $4.16 trillion
to use for climate investment
during that period of time.
And that's without factoring in
a bunch of asset managers
and you take an entity like BlackRock.
BlackRock is probably gonna
put another trillion in
maybe two over the course
of 10 years, who knows.
But if you start adding this up,
the accrued amount of
investment is gonna be
unlike anything we've ever seen
and people are already moving there.
Look at Tesla,
the value of Tesla is more
than more than ExxonMobil, BP,
And Chevron put together.
And all that does is make electric cars.
Oh, it does.
I mean, it's not minimalist,
but they're the reefs now
to zero emissions vehicles is intense
and you've got major automobile companies.
GM says they're gonna have no more
internal combustion engines after 2035,
Ford is moving in the same direction,
European car makers moving
in the same direction.
So the momentum of the
marketplace is also gonna provide
a level of impetus as well as
accountability in my judgment.
And people are gonna demand this,
this has taken on thanks to young people
sort of speaking out and
screaming about the future.
I think finally people
are saying, wait a minute
there's actually money to
be made in this enterprise.
We built out the grid of America.
We build cars, there's more work.
We're the fastest growing jobs in America
is wind turbine technician,
third fastest growing job in
America, solar panel installer.
And so they're gonna be a
lot of changes in our economy
that come from this.
I think it's the biggest
transformation theater
since the industrial revolution,
bigger by far than the technology
revolution of the 1990s
in computer desk, computers
and mobile phones and so forth.
This is gonna be gigantic.
And I think the marketplace realizes it.
And every boardroom in America
is now grappling with ESG
considerations, environment,
social and governance.
And you also have the
sustainable development goals
of the United Nations that
are hanging over people.
So we may finally see a moment
of global responsibility,
but as I said, 45% is
still about signed up
and we've got to move those countries.
And they're big China, India, Russia.
Some of the biggest emitters on the planet
20 countries are the equivalent
of about 75% of all emissions.
We are gonna continue to
work with those 20 countries.
- You were mentioning young people
in your answer that question.
And of course we're a university
and we have many students who are watching
this symposium today and
participating in Climate Day.
And I'd be interested in your
thoughts about what students,
what younger people can do
to influence Climate Policy.
And in particular, one of
the skills that you need
if you really want to be
someone who works on the policy
front and maybe has a career like yours.
- Well, I think the
skillset Peter is the same
as skillsets and other disciplines.
I mean, if you're a decent
student in whatever it is you do,
if you want to focus on climate
it's there to be focused on
and we need you desperately.
The fact is that, I mean
Yale is doing great job
in the various schools of instilling
a lot of interest in people.
I was privileged in my
fellows and in my seminar
to have people who were just
super motivated and focused,
a couple of whom I bumped
into down here in Washington,
one's working in the white house,
one's working in state department.
I mean, it happens very quickly.
So the fact is that
young people historically
and I say this with some measure of pride
because in the 1960s, a
lot of us became involved
in the civil rights movement of '64 '65
and the environment movement,
the women's movement
the peace movement, the war in Vietnam.
And the first thing I did
I remember it was marching
in and not just marching
but organizing Earth Day in Massachusetts
in new England back in 1970,
that mobilization of voters
is ultimately what happened
was a moment of accountability
based on environment.
And immediately the Congress
passed the Clean Air Act,
Safe Drinking Water,
Marine Mammal Protection,
Coastal Zone Management,
Endangered Species.
And we created the
Environmental Protection Agency
of our country.
That came out of young
people, student activism,
people going out and holding
the system accountable
to a large measure that's
happened already, with respect.
I think 2020 is the
first election since 1970
in which environment was
in fact a voting issue
and President Biden seized on it
had a major proposal in the
context of the campaign.
He's implementing it now, rejoining Paris
leaning on the summit,
beginning getting a 50 to 52%
target to reduce in America.
I think young folks are
to look at that and say,
gosh, you know we really played a role
in helping to make that happen,
but boy are we not finished?
This transition is gonna be a fight
and we need everybody
involved in this fight.
- Yale has such a long history
of educating young people
for service to state and community.
And I of course, hope that will continue.
We try to give students as
many opportunities we can
to learn those skills and be
inspired by people like you
and participate in what's
going on in Washington
or for that matter in
Hartford or New Haven.
Speaking of politics, what,
we have such highly
polarized political debate
in this country now.
And even climate change,
I say even climate,
is climate change is
highly politicized as well.
And yet it's gonna really
take a United effort.
It would seem to develop
solutions to address the crisis,
and just the ways that you suggest,
what can we do?
And is the role for universities
in addition to our convening function
to help bridge these political divides
and get people on the same
page and not make this yet
another area where a big
swath of the country simply
is not interested in engaging.
- Well, Peter, boy, that's the
big challenge to the country.
And there's the big question.
To some measure Yale's motto addresses
that Lux et veritas, we need truth.
We don't have a baseline for
truth in our system right now,
people actually have the ability
and have been creating their own facts,
creating their own reality.
Look at what's happening
with President Trump.
I mean, I don't want to politicize this
but what's happening in
this context of the big lie
and the big steel.
If that's the motivation of
a major party in our country
we really have a problem in
trying to get things done
in a bipartisan fashion.
And the only thing I can
really honestly think of
to say to people is
there's no automatic pilot
for democracy.
You don't just cruise along.
You can't cruise along.
You have to fight for what is the truth
you have to fight right now
that's been happening
and the demonstrations
and after George Floyd, the
Police Reform Initiative.
Now other kinds of things are emanating
out of this struggle.
And the victory of President Biden
is in fact a reflection of that,
of a large part of that battle.
He ran on restoring
the soul of our country
and wanting to restore some norms.
Not every norm, not
everything should be normal
and the same way all
the time changes change
and we embrace it, but it
can't be reckless, autocratic
authoritarian, anti-democratic change
in the United States of
America that people fall into
because they feel powerless or weak
or frustrated by what is not happening.
We have to fight for that very, very hard.
And given what's happening
in these laws being passed
around the country in
many many legislatures
that are going to make it
harder for people to vote.
I think that is a recipe for a potential
of real implosion of violence.
I mean, because what it's trying to do
is legitimize the steel
actually have a steel
create the predicate for it.
And that is gonna require
us to also fight back.
So this generation of the Yale students
is graduating at a moment
where we're not sending
a lot of troops off to
another country to die.
And that's the cause of action.
But what ought to be the cause
of action is their freedom
and Liberty and the baseline of truth
by which we can actually
function as a democracy
'cause without it, you don't
and you can't, and you won't.
- I certainly agree the, I know
we don't have a lot of time
but let me bring it back
to Yale for just a moment.
As you know we have announced
a planetary solutions
campus-wide project that
supports interdisciplinary
multidisciplinary research
on all things relevant
to climate change and its consequences.
We engage in campus behaviors
to try to change our own
make ourselves accountable
for the cost of carbon
we emit and be a model.
And we recently announced
some new guidelines
by which we're gonna evaluate
holdings in our endowment
where fossil fuel production
extraction is concerned.
Very recently, we received
a very large gift from FedEx
to support research as part of this
planetary solutions project
to support research on natural
methods of carbon capture.
And I'd be interested if you have,
if there are areas of
research that you think,
why isn't anybody studying this?
What could Yale be
focusing its attention on
through our planetary solutions project
that you think is an understudied
aspect of climate change?
Or it's a remediation
that we should seriously
try to organize that ourselves around.
- Direct air capture.
I mean, if we can figure
out how to suck this stuff
out of the atmosphere and put it to use
we're in the catbird seat,
two to three weeks of storage
that's Katy bar the door,
you just that's it we've
solved the problem.
And I think, I mean, I
think those are the biggest
obviously a lot of people are
chasing green hydrogen now
there's a lot of global endeavor for that.
I think it's going to be one
of the fuels of the future
without any question.
But the challenge for us, Peter
is can we move fast enough?
Not, will we move?
Ultimately, we're gonna get there.
And a certain percentage of
the population of the planet
will kind of learn how they'll
adapt and things will happen.
And we'll waste a lot
of money doing things
we never should have had to
do to survive as a species.
But a lot of people won't
there will be a massive
dislocation of human beings
with major food, disruption
and other challenges.
So the issue here is
speeding everything up.
If we can find ways to speed it up
we've got a much better
chance of arresting
the melting of Greenland and
the West Antarctic ice sheet
and the other major
disruptions that are coming
at at an alarming pace right now.
And so that's what I'd say.
I mean, you know Bill Gates in his book
sights that we need the
one of three miracles,
the miracle of storage,
the miracle of fusion,
or the miracle efficient,
and he's pursuing the fusion
with a next generation
model nuclear reactor
which has a lot of promise.
But the fact is that the science
has tell me that about 50%
of the emissions we need
to get to reach net zero
are going to come from
technologies we don't have today.
So it's sort of open season.
I mean, I think Yale well-advised
I think that's great money
that FedEx is invested.
That is the great endeavor
is to chase any number
of those possibilities.
Recognizing there are a lot
of people in certain sectors
you may want to isolate one or two,
particular avenues that is
not quite as a path as trod.
So we'll try and come up with something
but those are the biggies and nothing.
Anybody who can find a way we got
we had a serious methane challenge
because of the melting of the permafrost
and the melting of the tundra
and the massive exposure of
30 and 40,000 year frozen land
to a thawing is emitting massive amount
of heretofore contained
methane and methane is
20 to 80 times more damaging,
more destructive than CO2.
And it's now coming out in
amounts that are truly alarming
which will also exacerbate the gas debate
because gas is 87.7% methane
and it leaks, it leaks far
more in other countries
than here that we're
at about a 5% leakage.
And you add to that the
untapped unplugged wells
and mines from which methane is escaping.
One of President Biden's priorities
in the infrastructure bill is the capping
of those mines and those wells.
So those are the challenges.
And I think those are sort of
the centerpiece challenges.
- Well, Secretary Kerry
we appreciate you giving us time today.
And I want to allow you
to have the final word
but just to make sure that there's time
to express a little gratitude.
I want to thank you for
kicking off Climate Day for us,
and we miss you on campus.
It was great when you could
be with us more regularly.
And at some point we look
forward to welcoming you
back in a more regularized way.
In the meantime, it is great
to see you through Zoom.
And we do appreciate you
spending some time with us.
Any final words for our students?
- Yeah, first of all,
thank you Peter to you
and thank you to-
- My pleasure.
- Thanks to Yale for
doing the Climate Day.
My, on a note of optimism
which we ought to end on is
this is so doable.
That's what's so frustrating about it.
We know that we can move to massive level
of renewable usage, and then
you just need to balance
sort of 10 or 15% of your energy needs,
batteries are now reaching
a four hour length of time
for utility scale batteries.
And there are communities on the planet
that are at decarbonized status.
There are about four or five
of them and more coming,
so we can accelerate this.
And I see just fantastic
opportunity to make America fairer,
to deal with environmental injustice
that has characterized
a lot of the build out
and development of the last 40 50 years.
I think create millions, not, I think
all of the job analysis for
the long-term future show
that there are far far
more jobs to be created
in by going whole hog into this arena
of cleaning up the planet
and building out the new systems
that will modernize our
nations, lengthen our lives,
and increase the quality of
life, make us more secure.
All of those things.
And every economic analysis shows
it's far, far more
expensive to not tackle this
than it is to tackle it.
And we're already seeing that,
we spent $265 billion just cleaning up
after three storms a couple of years ago,
Irma, Harvey, and Maria,
we can do better than this.
And in the doing better
we will make our society
stronger, more resilient, fairer,
and more prosperous and healthier.
And so I'm excited about the prospects.
I really think this is worth the fight.
- Well, thank you.
Thank you for those
encouraging optimistic words.
We certainly have big challenge
ahead of us as a university
and as a country.
I want to thank you for joining us.
So once again, Secretary Kerry
and I want to welcome
everybody to a Climate Day
and very much hope that it
will be a stimulating day
for everybody participating with us today.
Thank you so much for being with us.